the Russian military in terms of
equipment has suffered over the last 25
plus years really since the dissolution
in soviet union with investment it's
been left with a large legacy of armored
fighting vehicles from the Cold War at
some point an all new system is needed
the t 14 is set to be Russia's new
generation of main battle tank the most
revolutionary feature of this tank is
that it features an unmanned main turret
it will be the first modern battle tank
valta crude turret the 125 millimeter
smooth war main gun why the reported is
the ability to fire guided anti-tank
missile summers as well as shells
evident from the imagery is the
introduction of a hard kill active
protection system incoming projectiles
such as rock da grenades and anti-tank
missiles will be sensed by the vehicle
an advanced current main battle tank
will be upwards of 5 million u.s.
dollars and the latest US Abraham's tank
would be in the region of 7.5 million
u.s. dollars the reported higher unit
cost of this tank that figure is likely
to include research and development
costs on last five years and potentially
the value of the contract over next
three-plus years c14 is a 4220 service
next year however we expected to only do
since very small numbers at this point